بعض الناس يلجاون الى سياراتهم الخاصه
للمبيت في داخلها نتيجه تضرر مساكنهم او
حتى اولئك الذين لم تتضرروا مساكنهم
فيلجاون الى السيارات خوفا من الهزات
الارتداديه ووقوع يعني
انهيارات في المباني خصوصا تلك المتصدعه
والايده للسقوط هناك يعني بالحديث عن
الهزات الارتداديه هل هناك انباء عن مزيد
منها هل توقفت لفتره ما
ما زالت السلطات تسجل فاطمه المزيد من
الهزات الارتداديه المئات من الهزات
الارتدائيه حتى الارتداديه حتى يوم امس تم
تسجيل اكثر من الف هزه ارتداديه وهي
بالتالي تشكل خطر كبير خصوصا على فرق
الانقاذ الموجوده في هذه المواقع هناك
مباني ما زالت صامده لكنها قايله للسقوط
بايه لحظه وبالتالي اي هزه ارتداديه ممكن
ان تؤدي الى كارثه جديده وتعقد من يعني
الازمه وهذا خطر يعني ما زال موجود وقائم
دائما الفرق الانقاذ والسلطات هنا تحذرنا
وتحذر اي شخص موجود في هذه المناطق من
الاقتراب من المباني لانها قد تسقط